[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كاس امم اسيا قطر
2023 يسعى المنظمون لهذه البطوله لتقديم
كافه الامكانات انجاحها ومن اهم هذه
العناصر المراكز الاعلاميه التي تقدم كافه
الخدمات
للاعلاميين ليس غريبا على دوله قطر وعلى
الدوحه عاصمه الرياضه العالميه ان توفر كل
سبل الراحه للاعلامي الوافد لتغطيه
البطولات اليوم
نشاهد توفير كل مستلزمات الراحه ل
الاعلاميين الحاضرين في المراكز الاعلاميه
التسهيلات التي تقدمها المراكز الاعلاميه
التجهيزات الحديثه كافه المعلومات كل هذا
يؤمن مساعده متميزه من اجل تقديم البطوله
بافضل صوره ممكنه جميع الخدمات متوفره واي
شيء ينقص اي اعلامي او اي صحفي بيوفر سواء
الاتحاد الاسي او اللجنه المنظمه ضمه
للبطولات كاس اسيا فيعني كل الشكر لهم
ويعني ما يعني يعني كل شيء ممتاز هنا يعني
في اي بطوله يعني العامل الاساسي هو
الاعلام والاعلام والاعلام يحتاج الى
مراكز اعلاميه في الاستادات في البلد
المستضيف لحتى يستطيع ان يقدم خدماته
الاعلاميه الى متلقيه طبعا قطر بعد
استضافه بطوله كاس العالم واكتساب الخبرات
والملاعب والمراكز الاعلاميه فانها ايضا
تقدم في هذه البطوله مراكز اعلاميه على
مستوى الحدث اكثر من 2000 اعلامي سيغطي
البطوله القاريه وهو رقم غير مسبوق في
البطولات
الاسيويه المنافسات الرياضيه من اهم سبل
نجاحها التغطيه الاعلاميه والتي بدورها
بحاجه الى عده مقومات من اهمها المراكز
الاعلاميه ايمن بطار الجزيره
الدوحه
he